[Applause]
he's the kind of guy bro he can give it
but he can't take it you know that
sounds very interesting but yeah but
like no one likes that kind of person
no one bro yeah and any friend group
that's why i like ascrine askren
you laugh at jokes i'll give that to him
he could take it
yeah he could take it yeah all those
guys job is great he's a great sense of
humor so i'm saying brother you and you
know that because you're in the business
like yeah basement is the kind of guy
like yo you better go you're a [ __ ] but
you go you
like cry try to fight you like try to
like i'm going to prison because i'm
going to kill you it's like probably
like
you're a [ __ ] like you know that makes
you a [ __ ] have you ever had people try
to pull up on you for yourself i've been
talking [ __ ] for [ __ ]
what seven years now nothing i have
death threats every single day
everything i never met any person that
like hated me i saw where to go
it's so interesting because you're going
to be at these events you guys have to
cross paths
i've been i've been you work out at the
same time i know you think i [ __ ] around
but i won't and so last time i was here
right and we went to uh
by the club that was called but mozball
was there right okay but like yeah
usually
you know like i walk in they don't pay
like you bring it to that table yeah
mazzo's right there
like this like turns his head i swear to
god so i was like okay so they put me on
a different table you know they're
bringing my name out on lights isn't
that his [ __ ] he gets so pissed
off bro he just leaves
and that [ __ ] talks like yo like
pull about whole foods like probably
he's not about it like that
really these guys are [ __ ] bro i'm
right next to him i can give
the owner of the club to like verify
like i don't lie bro
my girl was amazing like i was like bro
this [ __ ] got so mad that like
no one knew who he was
and they were giving my name like a
shine he just left i swear to god my
life
that's where my mom's life mm-hmm so
mozville had
walked out of here right in front of me
and this [ __ ] could be talking
about oh i'll pull up on you this and
that
bro he's not about that where did your
beef start just talking [ __ ] bro the guy
looks like he's uh
yeah he's a journeyman he's a he's a
glorified journeyman yeah bro he's
trash bro trash but he's more of himself
well you have to give it up
of course marketing is of course yeah
but yeah he's trash though
he's a terrible fighter chops terrible
you know i know i like him because like
he's like
he goes you know he's the kind of guy
that'll like fight you but like he's
he's not like a champion bro he's
but that's the thing he doesn't take his
serious brother mcdonald's before his
[ __ ]
thing like you know he's like a serious
bro but doesn't he seem like the guy i
mean the guy fought in backyards i don't
think he'd be scared to fight oh my god
i'm fighting the backyard
yeah when you fight bro that's not scary
like oh my god i found a backyard like
yeah
you're like i'll figure someone right
now yeah it doesn't make me tough you
know like when you know how to fight
doesn't make you tough
so you're not at all scared to fight
people like you don't be like me going
to that club and
picking up fight with someone like yo
okay does it make me tough no
that just makes me a [ __ ] you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah
like he like actually he's so tough on
this and that like fight someone that
knows how to fight like okay like
yeah yeah if you're fighting people know
how to fight you're tough but i mean
some people piss me off i'll [ __ ] them
up but like
like i don't know um when you when you
were were fighting in bellator right
yeah would you be nervous before your
fights i'm just trying to understand
your disposition like bro if you didn't
get nervous you didn't care
but mike tyson used to [ __ ] where's
the mike tyson fight that he tried to
climb out the arena
you know he was so nervous he'd try to
climb the ladder and leave on the top of
the arena
somebody that's you could look it up
george st pierre says he's the most
scared person ever he's the best fighter
you know dude
i did you watch him on rogan yeah
amazing bro his haircut though it's a
little crazy
it's a little crazy he looks like a guy
from street fighter but he looks like
yeah he looks like my [ __ ] salon
artist
they look salon bro she's ridiculous bro
but like he's the type of dude i don't
know about him
i know what what no about what have a
couple more sips and then tell us
what nobody what he loves the pie
[ __ ] he loves them
you know why he retired the first time
why why why he got stripper pregnant
no where he got he was a kid yeah so
where'd he go did he did he knee it
what did he she's like flying me
with that haircut i had to bear with a
haircut it was a charity event for him
really that's where he retired the first
time that he came back
interesting no that's look it up
no i look like i was jones bro you gotta
change the fact i believe you
the um the thing that i was watching the
uh clips from that interview right
and uh i even texted joe about it it was
so cool to watch someone that was so
clearly obsessed with fighting he's
obsessed nobody
that that's what we're talking about
tobacco like a martial artist like that
bro i cannot give respect to that
[ __ ]
every aspect of the game remember when
uh they were talking about uh most
awkward [ __ ] i've been down with
him before oh really
can we keep a conversation why because
you're not black with a fat ass
you had the fatty bro you a little
darker guys i'm not i'm not i'm not not
kagan
you wait wait you got a little something
a little something um
[Laughter]
you put his
i'm sitting on the ground right now
that's how big my hand is
so what else man no no no no i feel like
all serious what do you want what is
next for you like
here's the thing with what happened you
know something like jake
excited me bro cause these guys in
belter bro they don't
but they don't know how to sell a fight
these guys have like a thousand
followers two thousand followers then
like yeah
you're getting you're gonna make me go
through a [ __ ] six month or a three
month training camp
work my ass every day cut weight and
then no one even knows who the guy i'm
fighting
what do you fight at 170. and would you
fight lower
i could fight 55 i believe yeah i could
because how tall right now
i'll tell you i i'll tell you i'm six
foot six one on a good day
oh okay so so 155 would be tough for you
to get down to
i could do it though but that's a tough
cut but you got to give me the right
reason bro i'm going to
i mean that's one thing i agree with you
you're not going to do that for 40 grand
yeah like
yeah stop it i went my house before your
grand brother come on stop it right now
like j paul i was like yo give me i'll
give you a million after taxi i was like
six hundred thousand which is not that
much money for me to risk my knee my
knee is worth like
what 10 million to be the best player in
the world yeah how much is disney yeah
yeah yeah
you